[Musique]
bonjour jeanfred poisson et bienvenue
ici non loin du du Golf National de
saint-quanttin en Yveline puisque c'est
le le pit je vous en prie
assessayez-vous qui qui nous accueille
pour ce café politique au cours de la
prochaine demi-heure nous allons revenir
sur votre parcours vos engagements vous
êtes candidat à la primaire de la droite
en tant que président du Parti
Chrétien-Démocrate vous êtes aussi
député président de l'agglomération de
Rambouillet territoire et pour commencer
je vais vous faire réagir à quelquesuns
des des sujets d'actualité a commencé
par cette tuere aux États-Unis le 12
juin dernier et puis ce double meurtre
dans les ivelines à mananville à Orlando
l'État islamique a revendiqué cette
fusillade qui a fait plus de 50 morts
dans une boîte de nuit qui accueille
principalement la communauté gay 24
heures plus tard daesh revendique aussi
le meurtre de deux fonctionnaire de
police j'imagine que vous avez suivi
cette actualité particulière avec
attention parce que je vais aussi le
préciser vous vous occupez à l'assemblée
de la mission d'information sur les
moyens dont bénéficie justement daesh
l'État islamique oui c'est c'est deux
expressions supplémentaire de l'horreur
absolue et évidemment comment ne pas
être ému et consterné devant ces deux
massacres barbares c'est le signe
d'abord de ce que nos pays sont fragiles
qui sont d'une certaine manière en
situation de déséquilibre vis-à-vis de
personnes qui ne sont pas limité par
l'État de droit qui sont
psychologiquement certainement
déstructurés sont pas fous pour autant
pas nécessairement en tout cas et le
troisième signe que j'y vois c'est la
mutation de daesh qu'on est en train
d'observer en particulier le fait que il
y a encore quelques mois les ordres
d'attentat venaient de la tête de l'État
islamique en Irak ou en Syrie pour
animer ou provoquer des groupes et
inviter des groupes à commettre des
attentats depuis quelques temps on voit
bien que les consignes données par
l'État islamique central vise à dire aux
personnes qui sont partout là où elles
sont c'est pas la peine de venir en Irak
ou en Syrie reste là où vous êtes et
taper sur tout ce qui peut de près ou de
loin représenter l'état ou représenter
un mode de vie qui est celui que nous
contestons donc on voit bien qu'à la
fois la fragilité des démocraties et la
mutation actuelle de daesh sont à
l'œuvre dans ces deux attentats qui sont
évidemment absolument consternant et qui
ont provoqué chez moi une grande
tristesse et sur la question du du
financement justement de de DAEs
aujourd'hui de l'État islamique quel
quelle analyse quels éléments vous
pouvez livrer là-dessus parce que
j'imagine qu'il y a aussi peut-être une
certaine confidentialité sur certains
des propos alors oui d'autant plus que
la Commission n'a pas encore rendu son
rapport qui sera publié dans 3 semaines
ou un mois maintenant donc je ne peux
pas aller au fond des conclusions euh
évidemment ce que nous observons comme
beaucoup d'autres connaisseurs du sujet
c'est que les financements ont tendance
à se réduire que les financements de
masse représentent malgré tout environ
sans doute un milliard et demi d'euros
par an ce qui fait beaucoup d'argent et
troisièmement il y a un décalage total
entre le financement et l'argent que
récupère daesh sur place sur son
territoire du Khalifa
autoproclamé d'un côté et les très
petites sommes d'argent qui sont
nécessaires pour réaliser un attentat
ici tu es de policiers à madianville
qu'est-ce que ça ça ne coûte pas
d'argent le Bataclan c'est 30000 €
l'attentat de l'aéroport de Bruxelles
c'est 25000 donc entre 1 milliard et
demi d'un côté et puis 25000 ou 30000
qui peuvent facilement être collecté ici
il y a un décalage qui là encore nous
met en situation de difficulté pour
appréhender ces flux financiers modestes
et et pister un peu mieux et prévenir
autant que possible les attaques pour
revenir sur justement le le terrorisme
et l'attentat qui a touché qui a touché
Orlando ça a aussi touché un symbole qui
est la communauté homosexuelle aux
États-Unis le le climat est assez
difficile aujourd'hui pour cette
communauté le mississppi à légaliser la
discrimination envers les homosexuels
dans un but alors je précise he de
protection des libertés religieuses et
des convictions sincères de chacun il y
a aussi à la Caroline du Nord qui a
récemment interdit aux personnes
transsexuelles d'utiliser les toilettes
correspondant à leur identité de de
genre quel regard vous portez sur ce
climat euh homophobe clairement qui
touche les États-Unis et on y reviendra
tout à l'heure parce que je voudrais pas
non plus qu' qu' est d'amalgame vous
portez euh dans dans vos convictions
vous êtes opposé au mariage pour tous
euh mais on y reviendra un petit peu
plus tard dans cet entretien pour pas
qu' de de confusion sur les deux sujet
non moi je suis absolument opposé à tout
comp tout comportement discriminatoire à
l'égard de qui que ce soit je n'accepte
pas cette idée que des comportements
individuels puissent être criminalisés à
partir du moment où ils ne font pas de
tort particulier à autrui je n'aime pas
l'idée que comment dire on don doivent
interdire ou fustiger tel ou telle
communauté ou tel ou tel type de
pratique ou ou attachement enfin voilà
ça n'est pas du tout dans mon dans ma
manière de ma manière de voir je pense
que ce qui se passe aux États-Unis
encore que j'ai pas regardé ça dans le
détail mais ce que j'en perçois c'est
une certaine forme de crispion générale
des sociétés occidentales à l'égard des
crises sociales et économiques qui sont
vécu partout de la mondialisation qui
produit des ravages dans la tranquillité
d'esprit de toutes les personnes qui
sont concernées c'està-dire nous tous et
troisièmement la violence qui est exercé
pour pas dire la déstabilisation
qu'exerce l'islam en tant que tel sur
les sociétés occidentales provoque là
encore des sentiments de repli de gênees
de très grandes interrogation pour ne
pas dire d'inquiétude euh et
l'expression de ces inquiétudes parfois
peut aller jusqu'à renforcer les
systèmes d'interdiction ou le fait de
fuchiger telle ou telle communauté ça
n'est pas le mouvement que je souhaite
pour mon pays et je regrette de voir de
temps en temps même en France que des
propos exagérés
exagérément restrictifs ou coercitifs
commence à se tenir c'est une évolution
que je voudrais pas pour la France en
tout cas en dehors de l'actualité cette
émission permet aussi de mieux connaître
nos invités les élus leurs parcours
leurs engagements c'est ce qu'on va
faire au cours de la seconde partie de
cette
[Musique]
émission le café politique aujourd'hui
avec Jean-Frédéric Poisson député
président d'agglomération président du
Parti Chrétien-Démocrate candidat à la
primaire à droite en vue de la
présidentielle vous avez 53 ans vous
avez été leumire de Rambouillet en 2004
lorsque Gérard Larché s'est mis en
retrait avec son entrée au gouvernement
rambbouillet vous avez eu aussi votre
premier mandat en tant que conseiller
municipal c'était en 1995 au-delà de de
ces mandats ces élections votre
engagement politique véritablement il
remonte à quand c'est c'était pas
exactement un engagement politique
c'était un engagement social je suis
comme dirait d'autrre un pur produit du
monde socioculturel un socioocul comme
on dit dans les gazettes j'ai passé une
quinzaine d'années de ma vie dans les
banlieux nord de Paris à villve lagaren
dans les cités HLM j'étais un jeune
président de Maison des Jeunes et de la
Culture j'ai été élu dans cette maison
comme secrétaire de l'association à 17
ans président à 19 et j'avais à cette
époque la charge d'animer cette belle
association où on faisait à la fois des
ateliers d'informatique c'était les
premiers il y avait une radio libre il y
avait des systèmes d'insertion
professionnel les gretap PO qu'on a
monté avec l'État il y avait des
activités toute nature et puis une
présence particulière à l'égard des des
enfants de cette commune qui étaient un
peu moins doué à l'école qui allaiit un
peu moins vite qui était un peu plus un
peu plus fragilisé dans une ambiance
d'étudiants j'ai découvert à cette
occasion aussi le monde de l'animation
puisque dans cette période j'ai
également été responsable de colonies de
vacances pour les enfants de la DAS et
donc dans cet univers là j'ai découvert
au
fond la politique sans le savoir
c'est-à-dire l'action politique et
sociale mais en dehors des partis et
pendant des années des années je n'y ai
pas pensé j'étais parti plutôt pour une
le métier d'enseignant que j'ai exercé
pendant 2 ans je suis devenu ensuite
cadre d'entreprise et directeur de
ressources humaines c'est mon métier
d'origine et puis la politique m'a
rattrapé la première Mo des années 90
avec le travail auprès de Christine
Boutin puis mon entrée au conseil
municipal de Rambouillet donc ça remonte
à la fois loin et pas si loin que ça et
cette vie professionnelle que vous avez
mis entre parenthèses en vous engageant
plus encore en politique est-ce que
c'est vraiment une parenthèse d'ailleurs
est-ce que vous allez la refermer un
jour cette parenthèse politique écoutez
vous savez le propre des mandats
politiques c'est qu'on sait comment
quand ça commence et on sait pas quand
ça s'arrête donc tout est possible je je
suis prêt psychologiquement d'ors et
déjà à à devoir faire autre chose que de
la politique même si mon engagement
particulier parlementaire me passionne
j'ai parfois la claire compréhension du
fait que un jour ça s'arrêtera forcément
donc il faudra prendre des disposition
pour retrouver une activité je pense que
j'y suis prêt maintenant ça me fera ça
sera sans doute difficile parce que on
ne s'engage pas comme je le fais en y
passant le plus clair de son temps et de
son énergie sans que ça finisse par
créer aussi des habitudes en plus de la
passion mais voilà surtout qu'
aujourd'hui votre énergie vous la
consacré à à briguer ce cette primaire
en tout cas pour ensuite vous présenter
la présidence de la République déjà il
faut passer donc par lespreuv de la
primaire et selon les sondages vous êtes
crédité entre 1 2 % et ça ça n'atteint
pas votre détermination non bien sûr que
non d'abord on est au tout début de la
campagne premièrement
de c'est en novembre donc il reste
encore 5 bons mois pour pour faire tout
ça premièrement deuxièmement la campagne
n'a pas vraiment
démarré parce que la liste définitive
des candidats dans laquelle je serai
forcément sera publié le 21 septembre
prochain donc dans deux bons mois tris
bons mois même de il y a encore beaucoup
de temps beaucoup de choses à faire et à
dire et puis j'auris au moment du
premier tour animé dans tout le pays une
centaine de réunions publiques en
métropole et en outreem et mon projet
aura été diffusé et donc je pense que
les équilibres politiques seront
modifiés sensiblement d'ici le mois de
novembre prochain la motivation c'est
pas ce qui vous manque on l'a bien
compris je reviens aussi sur un épisode
aussi de votre carrière politique en
septembre 2009 Christine Boutin n'est
plus ministre elle choisit de ne pas
reprendre son poste de députés bien que
suppléant vous devez repasser devant les
électeurs pour continuer à siéger vous
l'emportez d'une poignée de voix une
voix finalement Conseil constitutionnel
annule le scrutin nouvelle élection vous
êtes battu mais vous l'emportez lors du
scrutin suivant quelques années quelques
années plus tard comment vous avez vécu
cette cette période vous avez été écarté
du mandat de député ben d'abord j'ai
repris une activité professionnelle
c'est-à-dire je suis revenu à mes
premiers amours j'étais avant d'entrer à
l'Assemblée nationale jusqu'en 2007 le
patron d'un cabinet de conseil à Paris
dont j'étais également de fondateur qui
est spécialisé dans l'organisation et
les ressources humaines donc j'ai
remonté une petite entreprise
unipersonnel j'ai repris mon bâton de
pèlerin et j'ai recommencé à gagner ma
vie comme je savais le faire avant
d'entrer à l'Assemblée en me disant de
deux choses l'une si en juin 2012 je
suis réélu bien je cesserai cette
activité pour me consacrer au Parlement
si je ne suis pas élu député je
continuerai cette activité j'ai été
réélu donc j'ai arrêté cette cette
activité là qui m'a occupé et bien
occupé pendant les deux années où
effectivement les électeurs m'ont mis en
congé ça m'a permis également de
compléter ma formation philosophique par
un master de droit social que j'ai passé
tout près à l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin dont je suis fier d'être
un des diplômés de cette belle maison
ivelinoise et dont vous êtes pas si
éloigné la plupart du temps la ville de
de Rambouillet j'imagine pour vous un
aspect particulier parce que c'est là où
vous avez été élu et vous avez vos vos
attaches politique Gérard Larché est un
personnage important justement de de de
la commune de Rambouillet et de ce
bassin quel rapport vous vous entretenez
avec lui excellent depuis que nous avons
opéré une double passation de pouvoir en
2004 quand il est rentré au gouvernement
que je suis devenu maire en 2007 quand
il a quitté le gouvernement et que donc
j'ai remis ma fonction entre les mains
du préfet comme la loi le prévoit il est
redevenu maire de Rambouillet nous avons
gardé de cet épisode des liens tissés
d'une très grande confiance nous sommes
très différents lui et moi à peu près
aussi différentes que deux hommes
peuvent l'être mais il y a entre nous
cette espèce de j'allais dire une
certaine forme de complicité je peux
dire ça comme ça encore une fois une
très grande confiance une très grande
écoute réciproque et et il n'y a pas une
décision qui soit prise sur le
territoire depuis maintenant une
quinzaine d'années j'étais son premier
adjoint en 2001 sans que l'un ou l'autre
nous en échangions et nous avons
maintenant la possibilité en plus
d'échanger sur le plan national et
international donc nous nous voyons
souvent nous passons bon moment ensemble
et nous avons nous
partageons trois passions la politique
et la France bien sûr la bonne chair et
la chasse donc sa cré des liens ce qui
est propre au bassin de remouiller
finalement on en revient à cette
primaire vous représentez le Parti
Chrétien Démocrate et à ce titre vous
l'avez dit vous n'avez pas besoin de
passer par l'étape des parinages donc
vous êtes aujourd'hui le seul candidat
finalement officiel à cette primaire
mais est-ce que le Parti Chrétien
déémocrate est bien connu de la
population nous avons réalisé un petit
micro trotoir et puis je vous laisse
réagir juste après j'ai entendu parler
mais c'est tout je connais rien rien du
tout j'imagine que c un parti à vocation
à la fois politique et religieuse euh
c'est Christine Boutin non ben moi je
suis catholique donc j'aurais tendance à
à pouvoir suivre ce ce genre de parti
mais malheureusement je me retrouve pas
dans dans la démarche de Madame Boutin
là elle a des
positions qui sont peut-être chrétiennes
mais qui sont pas très démocrates dans
ce micro trottoir on parle beaucoup de
Christine Boutin alors elle a été la la
fondatrice de ce mouvement en 2009 vous
en êtes le Président vous depuis 2013 il
y a encore l'ombre de Christine Boutin
qui plane c'est pas une nbre c'est pas
une nbre qui plane c'est c'est beaucoup
plus que ça et là le parti a été créé
d'abord en 2001 il a changé de nom en
2009 pour tout un tas de raison et j'en
suis le président depuis maintenant 2
ans et demi euh il n'y a pas de il y a
jamais eu de volonté de la part du parti
grétin déémocrate de d'évacuer comment
dire je ne sais pas quelle forme d'ombre
comme vous disiez de de Christine a
fondé cette formation politique elle l'a
animé pendant des années c'est normal
que son nom lu soit attaché je pense que
enfin je ne sais pas de quand date votre
votre micro trottoir quelques jours il y
a quelques jours très bien donc ça veut
dire que ça confirme que nous avons des
progrès à faire en terme de notoriété et
justement la campagne sert à ça il faut
encore se se faire connaître et pour
vous faire connaître pardon vous avez
plusieurs déclarations quelquefois qui
font toujours parler en tout cas qui
font toujours du bruit le 9 juin dernier
vous avez déclaré c'était dans la
tribune la manière dont un certain
nombre de musulmans envisagent la vie en
société pose problème aux Français il
faut aussi peut-être supprimer le
Conseil français du culte musulman
est-ce que vous pouvez nous clarifier un
petit peu ces différentes déclaration le
Conseil français du culte musulman a été
inventé pour constituer une autorité de
référence pour l'ensemble des musulmans
de notre pays qui sont très
majoritairement sunites et chez les
sunites à la différence des chiites la
notion d'autorité spirituelle ou
religieuse n'existe pas qui soit une
autorité qui soit imposée comme capacité
de créer des obligations c'est par
ailleurs un une instance dans laquelle
des puissances étrangères le Maroc et
l'Algérie pour ne pas les citer continue
de se livrer une bagarre diplomatique
par le biais des mosquées ou des consuls
à interposer ce que la France ne peut
pas accepter plus longtemps j'ai dit ça
d'ailleurs exactement en ces termes au
présidents du Sénat marocain et au
président de la Chambre des députés
marocaines quand je les ai vu au mois de
mars dans leur propre pays à à Raba
alors il faut supprimer cette
institution parce qu'elle ne remplit pas
son rôle qu'elle ne sert à rien il faut
sans doute organiser autrement quelque
chose qui serait une instance dans
laquelle les musulmans et l'État
français discutent sur la manière dont
on peut accepter l'expression d'un
certain nombre de cultes euh comment
dire dans le pays mais pas comme ça et
pas avec les personnes qui y sont c'est
ça la porte de sortie mais la pratique
de l'Islam n'est pas impossible en
France mais j'espère que la preuve
qu'elle ne l'est pas c'est c'est c'est
pas la pratique de l'Islam euh que des
hommes et des femmes croient que Allah
est grand que M son prophète qu'il faut
prier CIN fois par jour en se tournant
vers la MEC faire le jeûne faire le
hadge le pèlerinage est respter comment
dire un certain nombre d'obligations
tout ça me choque pas du tout c'est la
liberté de conscience elle est garantie
par les lois françaises et par la
Constitution c'est notre grandeur c'est
notre honneur et ma responsabilité de
croyant de législateur de citoyens et de
philosophe me conduit à dire que il faut
impérativement respecter cela mais ça ne
peut pas se faire dans n'importe quelle
condition ça ne peut pas se faire à la
sauvage ça ne peut pas se faire de
manière brutale et revendicative ou
agressive à l'égard du corps social
français ça ne peut pas se faire en
tenant n'importe quel discours y compris
ceux qui invitent à je ne sais pas
quelle violence à l'égard de la France
parce que c'est la France ou ou telle
personne tout ça doit être encore une
fois réglementé mais on doit prendre
l'engagement à l'égard des musulmans
qu'effectivement ils doivent avoir en
France la possibilité de pratiquer leur
culte dans des conditions décentes voilà
vous disiez tout à l'heure vous disiez
tout à l'heure c'est des choses qu'il
faut dire qu'il faut affirmer ça veut
dire que ça reste un un tabou peut-être
même dans votre famille politique et
pour aller plus loin dans la question
vous vous situez où sur cet échquier
politique vous avez déclaré ces propos
qui ont été repris par le journal Marian
que vous vous sentiez plus proche d'une
Marion maréchal Le Pen par exemple que
d'une Natalie cosisco Moris Marion
maréchal Le Pen oui sur les sujets en
particulier qui touchent euh à la
dignité de la personne humaine et à la
défense de la vie qui sont pour le parti
chrétienddémocrate et pour moi des
sujets extrêmement importants et c'est
vrai que il y a dans au sein de de la
famille des républicains certains de mes
collègues certains amis même pour
lesquels enfin qui ont sures sur ces
sujets des positions qui sont qu'on peut
qualifier de libéral libertaire pour
aller vite euh et qui ne sont pas ma
manière de voir les choses euh
maintenant euh il y a ou j'ai à titre
personnel avec le Front national un
certain nombre de différence très très
marqué et et je pense pour beaucoup en
tout cas irréconciliable je suis contre
la préférence nationale parce que je
considère que c'est antinomique de la
notion de mérite qui qui m'est cher et
dans laquelle je crois je ne crois pas
que leur vision de l'Europe soit
pertinente et je ne crois pas qu'il
faille quitter l'euro ni l'Union
européenne je suis opposé à la peine de
mort parce que je ne crois pas qu'on
puisse attenter à la vie d'une personne
en dehors des cas de légitime défense je
ne pense pas que sur les sujets qui
touchent à la vie et la dignité de la
personne humaine non plus le Front
national soit exactement sur des
positions que dans lesquelles je crois
donc ces quatre différences là sont pour
moi en tout cas irréductible et si vous
n'êtes pas candidat à cette
présidentielle si vous n'êtes pas
désigné candidat pour la famille des
républicains vous serit derrière celui
ou celle qui sera désignée Si Al Jup par
exemple l'emporte c'est écoutez c'est
l'engagement que j'ai pris parce que la
charte des républicains sur pour la
primaire elle comporte une obligation
pour ceux qui ne la gagneront pas qui
consiste comme vous venez de dire très
justement à le suivre et à le soutenir
il y a un point qu' va falloir éclaircir
entre-temps et c'est là qu'on voit que
nos formations politiques de la droite
et du centre n'ont pas cette culture de
la primaire quelles sont les obligations
de celui qui
gagne parce que les les perdants enfin
les perdants eux sont obligés de suivre
très bien moi j'aimerais bien qu'on me
dise à quoi celui qui Gan s'engage donc
vous vous attendez en fonction du poids
que vous allez représenter ou les autres
candidats représentant candidat
représent d'être entendu programme dans
l'élaboration du progamme exactement
vous avez tout compris la primaire n pas
autre chose qu'une conquête de levier et
de territoire donc nous verrons bien à
l'issue du premier tour comment se
profile la mosaïque des différents
candidat sachant qu'aujourd'hui nous ne
savons pas très bien qui concourra et
qui ira jusqu'au bout de la candidature
et' un sujet peut-être qui sera
compliqué pour vous mettre d'accord
c'est celui du mariage pour tous parce
que vous y êtes opposé vous voulez
revenir sur cette loi nous avons réalisé
là aussi un micro trottoir pour avoir
quelques réactions est-ce que le
prochain président doit revenir ou non
sur ce mariage pour tous écoutterz ahah
non ce qui on va pas commencer à revenir
même si j'étais pas pour en compte c'est
une bonne chose il faut laisser la
liberté aux gens d'avoir leurs
sentiments et de pouvoir les réaliser en
couple quel que soit le couple
absolument pas parce que la tolérance et
que chacun accepte la différence s passé
à en commission et voilà quand c'est
passé c'est passé on va pas revenir
dessus je pense que chacun est libre de
faire ce qu'il veut et on peut laisser
la liberté aux gens c'est tout
globalement il semble plutôt voir même
si on écoute les sondages une majorité
pour ne pas revenir ça a étéé décidé
vous votre proposition c'est quoi de
revenir catégoriquement ou en tout cas
de faire un référendum sur le sur le
sujet quel que soit le moyen c'est la
compétence du Parlement donc le
Parlement peut exercer le droit de
modifier ou d'abroger les lois qu'il a
prises non je rapproche ce micro
trottoir d'une autre enquête qui a été
publiée a quelques jours qui dit que
presque tr/4 des électeurs et des
sympathisants des familles politiques de
la droite et du S souhaite qu'on
revienne sur ch toi d'une manière ou
d'une autre j'y été opposé pour deux
raisons la première prière c'est le fait
que de mon point de vue le fait de
marquer de fonder une société sur une
cellule qui soit différenciée sur le
plan sexuel c'est quelque chose qui est
conforme à ce que je crois euh comment
dire la l'organisation sociale doit être
et
deuxièmement lorsqu'on légalise le
mariage pour les couples de même sexe et
bien on va nécessairement c'est
d'ailleurs exactement ce qui est en
train de se produire vers
l'adoption des enfants et vers surtout
la question des mères porteuses c'est
c'est exactement ce que nous allons euh
débattre ces jours-ci ce qui est en
discussion à l'Assemblée depuis la
semaine dernière euh et qui euh et qui
reviendra sur le tapis à chaque fois
parce que c'est une question essentielle
euh moi j'entends ce que disent les
personnes qui sont interrogées euh le
droit d'exprimer ses sentiments bien
entendu la liberté parfaitement d'accord
j'ai rien à c'est pas ça le sujet euh
vous savez quand on j'aurais marié dans
ma vie euh un peu plus de 150 couples à
la mairie de grandbouillet depuis 95
1995 euh on on parle pas d'amour dans un
marage civil c'est pas le sujet le maire
est pas là pour dire oui oui vous AZ je
vous Marie c'est pas du tout la question
et heureusement de quel droit on serait
juge de ça la loi n'est pas là pour dire
vous avez le droit de vous aimer ou pas
le droit de vous aimer ce sont deux
régistres différents personne n'empêche
quiconque de s'aimer si non c'est pas ça
la question la question c'est les
incidences qu'une loi je parle d'une loi
peut avoir sur le fonctionnement social
en général et sur un certain nombre de
respect des droits fondamentaux d'autres
personnes que ceux qui sont concernés
par la loi c'est ça la question du
mariage pour tous pas autre chose et
c'est la raison pour laquelle comme je
le répète une très grande majorité des
électeurs de nos familles politiques la
droite et du centre comme le montre en
particulier une enquête récente mais de
manière assez régulière je plaide pour
que effectivement cette loi soit
abrangée pur Mo et simplement je vous
posais la question du référendum tout à
l'heure quel mode de présidence vous
vous souhaitez vous dénoncez un
afféblissement de la fonction
présidentielle avec ce ce dernier
quinena je pense à Bruno Lemire par
exemple qui lui en cas de de victoire à
la présidentielle s'il est désigné
candidat en tout cas déjà souhaite
gouverner dans en tout cas dans un
premier temps par par ordonnance pour
réaffirmer aussi l'autorité du président
à qui on aura confié un mandat est-ce
que vous partagez cette opinion d'abord
le le gouvernement par ordonnance
n'affirme pas l'autorité du Président de
la République il affirme l'autorité du
gouvernement car c'est le gouvernement
qui est habilité à gouverner par
ordonnance c'est pas le chef de l'État
premier point deuxième point l'autorité
qu'il s'agit de rétablir ne peut pas
c'est pas un problème de muscle c'est
pas c'est pas c'est pas ppeille on est
pas en train de faire les tatouages avec
des boîtes d'épinard non ce qui établit
l'autorité d'un chef c'est que il exerce
dans le périmètre qui est le sien la
totalité des pouvoirs qui lui sont
confiés mais en respectant parfaitement
les prérogatives des personnes qui
travaillent à son côté et ce qui se
passe en France qui est extrêmement
significatif de notre démocratie et
c'est sans doute une chose qu'on voit
assez peu dans les pays voisins à cause
de la la du caractère bicéphale de
l'État français il y a un président de
la République et un premier ministre il
y a ça nulle par ailleurs les deux ont
des
pouvoirs la très grande difficulté c'est
qu'il ne se marche pas dessus et en
général quand il se marche dessus c'est
le président de la République qui marche
sur un bout desplatement du Premier
ministre et à ce moment-là le chef de
l'État s'affaiblit pas le premier
ministre c'est la raison pour laquelle
dans le projet que je présente dans le
cadre de la primaire j'ai la volonté de
dire le rôle du chef de l'État
c'est de rétablir la fonction
protectrice de l'État dans sa puissance
régalienne d'un côté et c'est de faire
prendre les dispositions pour que nous
reconstitution à nouveau un tissu
solidaire et un peuple ce que nous
sommes malheureusement de moins en moins
nous sommes plutôt une juste ta position
de communauté qu'un peuple a proprement
parlé la mise en place la mise en œuvre
la déclinaison ce sera le travail du
gouvernement le chef et la pour le chef
de l'État est là pour garantir
l'application de la Constitution
vérifier qu'effectivement les grandes
orientations sont respectées par les
gouvernants mais une fois que vous avez
fixé un CAP et un cadre le Premier
ministre dirige la politique de la
nation c'est lui qui doit faire son
affaire des différentes des différents
aspects donc c'est pas un problème de
aller vite passer en force non c'est pas
du tout la question et je pense que il y
aurait au contraire une très grande
crispation de la majorité nouvellement
nommée quelle qu'elle soit en plus il
est de notre camp à l'Assemblée
nationale en juin 2017 si jamais la
première chose qu'on lui disait ce
serait mesdames et messieurs vous signez
en bas vous allez nous laisser faire on
s'occupe de tout ça je crois pas que
dans le contexte actuel ce soit très
prudent juste un dernier mot très
rapidement pour pour conclure et ça va
aussi dans le sens de ce que vous disiez
votre projet c'est un projet de
civilisation pour la France et non pas
forcément de de gestion dans les grandes
lignes c'est ça ça veut dire oui que je
pour avoir eu l'occasion de beaucoup me
déplacer à l'étranger ces derniers temps
je vois qu'il y a à l'égard de la France
une très grande
attente de présence
d'influence de coopération d'aide de
soutien et et vraiment en Afrique du
Nord au prochorient j'ai passé beaucoup
de temps depuis un an et demi maintenant
j'ai entendu cela ça n'est pas vrai que
là d'ailleurs je crois qu'il a chez les
Français
euh toujours la fierté d'appartenir à
cette grande nation que nous sommes mais
en même temps de Mo en moins de motifs
pour nourrir cette fierté et il faut
leur redonner ses raisons je pense
qu'ils n'attendent que ça troisièmement
considérer qu'effectivement toutes les
mesures de gestion qui pourraient être
prises ne serviront à rien si elles ne
sont pas prises au service d'un peuple
qui est reconstitué et sous l'autorité
d'un État qui a retrouvé ses pouvoirs
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle le
peuple et l'État sont les deux seuls
sujets qui m'intéressent pour la
présidentielle il m'intéresse vous
comprenez ce que je veux dire ce sont
les deux parord d'importance qui guident
mon projet et mon action le reste après
pour la mise en œuvre ça fera partie des
modalités de discussion merci jean-féric
poisson d'avoir participé à ce café
[Musique]
politique